you've had some trouble keeping your
driver's license is this not the case
we've talked about this before but
you've had your driver's license taken
away a few times because of some
infractions
i swear to you i cannot make this story
up i'm coming from the
from court today i went to court today
like
like no i know i know you're asking me a
serious question i swear to goodness i
was in court today
renewing my driver's license again
because it got suspended i'm a speed
demon you're a speed demon
speed demon i don't i don't respect the
law and i don't feel like i have to
because i'm a sex symbol
now when you do this when you do that
officer you don't understand no i'm a
sex symbol i feel like i'm supposed to
go fast
sexy people are supposed to drive fast
yes uh no but dude i don't know why i
cannot keep a license man it's the worst
thing ever
but today in in uh in the courthouse
like that the officer recognizes me and
he's like hey i'm gonna get you out of
here fast
he gets me to the front i literally tell
the guy i said guilty
i just want to pay it so that okay so to
give me my paper so i can go pay it
there's a long line
of people paying it so i said you know
what i'm gonna try to bribe the person
in the front i'm gonna say look uh
i'll pay your ticket if you just let me
go in front of you right so my friend's
like no don't do that let's just get one
of the cops
and see if they can just you know get
you in front i said okay the guy gets me
in the front officer comes up puts me in
the front it's a true story
one guy is always one guy in line he
yells out
why does he get to cut everybody and i'm
standing there right i'm just standing
there
and i happen to look and everybody in
line is mexican and i was like it's just
there's nothing i can say to not look
racist
i was like uh i'm famous and uh
that never works not only did it not
work not only did it not work the guy
says
listen i've been here for an hour you
gotta open up another window
or he doesn't go and some girl calls
herself taken up from me and it was like
the worst
defense case i've ever seen in my life
she was like you need to understand
that people like him make us happy and
this is our way
to show him our appreciation that's
fantastic no
it wasn't a fantastic offense she got
booed
wrong when you have to tell people
you're famous it's never good it's never
good
how dare you i'm famous
we have to get to this real husbands of
hollywood this is kind of a fake reality
show it's the
it's the fakest realest reality show
that's going to be on television
that's the best way to describe it for
those who do not know uh i basically did
a television show where i'm mocking
reality
uh when you think of tv shows with rally
you think of the basketball wives you
think of
housewives of atlanta and orange county
right so everybody always talks about
this this stuff is messed these women
just fight and argue
so i said i want to make fun of it so
what i did was get a group of men who
weren't afraid to make fun of ourselves
and we basically embellished our lives
me nick cannon boris kojo robin thicke
dwayne martin faison love nelly a group
of a group of great people
jb smoove we're all on this show and
it's the most hilarious
frantic i guess you could say uh
outrageous behavior that you'll see from
men
all right we have a clip here this is i
don't know if we need anything to set it
up probably not real husbands of
hollywood we just set it up it's a sexy
clip
so my snowboard hits a rock and then i
go flying through the air i hit a cabin
by the time i wake up
mick jagger is giving me hot chocolate
no way spiked with cognac yeah that's
crazy
really mick jagger how old is he now
what is he
dead and a half i don't want to talk
about that why don't we talk about
how how outdated this hair is whoa come
on kevin
this is my friend there's no reason to
keep disrespecting him like that
no dude but don't worry about it nelly
you know what that's pretty funny kevin
you should do stand-up
uh you know i do stand up and you know
i'm one of the best at it
second best second best of who second
best of me you're a damn lie
i'm the first best you know it stole my
pickle joke i've been doing that pickle
joke for years
shut up jb